[Music]
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're going to watch what
if season 2 episode 6 season's been good
so far been great way better than season
one nothing is quite reach the heights
yet emotionally I would say of the
doctor strange one but dang animation
and overall
consistency I'm impressed with this
season I got to say Coy I got to say I'm
impressed you impressed I think uh fa
three and four of Marvel have highs and
lows that rival phases one and two but
one and two are more consistent this is
Phase 1 and two quality yeah man this is
great stuff great you know it's great
too if you guys tell us what you think
of episode 6 tell me what you think of
the characters what I'll say maybe I
spoiled it koi but tell me tell us in
the comments guys leave a like don't
think anymore don't think anymore leave
a like on this video subscribe and click
this notification Bell you know reaction
for the next episode is up did you
figure it out I think it's the new
character took me a
second
thanks to pre for help down these
highlights also fly scratch and watch
along where you sink with your own copy
of what if available it's the first time
happened super sexy rejects over at our
patreon page thank you to all been
joining us even for this wh if Journey
you guys have been awesome Pome that's
one the best ways to support this
channel let's do it
quick asgard's nightmare is the same in
many realities the flames Ragnarok Odin
entrusted the tesak to a village on
Earth after achieving an age of Peace wa
look at that animation
dang fire came for asgar before he had
the chance
Ser
[Music]
wow waa this is sick why does this look
so
epic damn cool they threw Arcane the
destruction of Asgard would lead to new
wonders from a single Ember of the past
the Tesseract survived
Ragnarok okay find a new home in a new
world oh the new world that's cool I
wonder if Americans made this episode M
Real Americans white Americans oh right
of the Americans there's only one
American I know of it's more than a
linear path said Benedict cumber bash
was in this episode who was he playing
one of The Real Americans Sherlock that
British man
one of The Real
[Music]
Americans man I love
corn maze I don't like corn you don't
like corn I don't like corn dude on the
cob by itself with butter and potatoes
on the cheese oh man corn the cob is one
of my favorite things to eat comments
you guys like corn hey what do you think
about corn let us
know
I have to read this is
America we don't read here you speak
English in my
show
wat okay
wat oh like water okay kahori I think
the new character right they're all
technically new characters that's true
the
one to be an ech know you're sorry don't
mean to be that
guy
[Music]
W I wonder what specific language you're
speaking Tess
power what's the sky world to
them uh that's not the American where no
no it's not
frankly so far I love the choice to do
this because this feels very refreshing
and so different than the pace and where
it is in the season just after
halfway don't trust the Ducks they bring
bad
luck
our people they look
happy hey oh Spaniards they can't kador
first
[Music]
right so is this episode what if
settlers didn't wipe out most of a race
of people and take over their land not
sure Americans would make that story
what if we didn't horribly ruin a na
that allowed us to make this story
you're watching
today oh decoy Lake decoy hey
hey oh kill them before they find out go
in the lake yo I think you're right I
think whatever's in this Lake the powers
and stuff is going to link to Ekko I
think you're I think you're absolutely
right about
that
golly damn some
blood
wow the structures are
gorgeous
whoa Destiny awaits
you it's like there's no water around
her
cuz we don't know when the testra first
came to Earth so fair it could still be
useful in in the
cannon whoa they like embrace
it so the sky world is like an actual
plane after the fall of Asgard
fascinating the tessera took on a second
life among cord's ancestors
remember all the ancestor stuff in the
phase four has been very thorough
gifting its power to the lake Warriors
adventurers and other Noble tribes
people disappeared like
constellations greed and grief ignited a
terrible battle amongst the surrounding
Nations Peace was made and the lakes's
blood soaked Shores were deemed cursed
deterring all from returning to it
interesting keeping it safe all but one
what
[Music]
cool so much about Elements of
Life
[Music]
for you can't I don't know if it's
oneway
Street that's where Ben a cumber batch
comes in handy ah
portals May should have Ben to come
batch in the title it does kind of give
us a place to wait for
[Laughter]
okay got you that makes
sense he is Sinister I really appreciate
that they put most of this in a
different language all of it so far
except the opening right yeah and two
different languages
is the implication that the Watchers
connected to these people that'd be
interesting seemed like the
eyes they
gone on
Deet Mary Sue she learned fast in her
recite 30 minute episodes too much power
too fast
F can't you build something to get to
the portal or pull her with the telek
right and
then oh there you
go maybe
not nail it nail
it
ouch absolutely beautiful I love the use
of variety of colors and the painting
style is really cool they really threw
down for a different style for this
one but it doesn't feel alien to the
style it it it Blends nice yeah give
call
[Music]
wow Buffalo leaves Trail look at that
it's like
Speeders cool what a fast fting new
aspect of the world to incorporate into
Marvel join alongside
them it's a great sense of like
landscape and scale
[Music]
[Laughter]
man
it feels like scopic there's depth to
all this good point
yeah
wow whoa she Dark Knight flipped that
animal oh
cool pick up those five big ones G dig
ones you know what they
[Music]
I feel like no one ever runs into a
conflict here seems chill it's a nice
place she's forgotten all about the
people suffering back home I got these
shiny Jewels why does she have such a
special power cuz she's the new Marvel
[Music]
character that looks weirdly
delicious
I would love to reveal that bened batch
is playing him we been waiting this
whole time he's playing a Spanish voice
[Music]
character this episode's doing an a very
interesting job of capturing the horrors
and wonders of this exploration also
like our blind belief in things like you
don't have about that water like I
mean I still jump into
it the depth of of the animation still
so impressive I feel like they threw
down their best work on this one for
animation I'm talking probably because
like they're introducing a whole new
element in new characters sure they had
to make it really count also there's a
level of delicacy and sensitivity to the
world so it adds to that
yeah
no he's like Thomas and Pocahontas yeah
get
down oh NE she is the
one she is the one she's got all the
powers don't use these powers for
evil there's no talking with these
people
that's weird what a weird
concept oh it's trying to help her get
home bring the portal to you you
get used this power for good
plot-wise I do think it it's really cool
it's beautiful and I love a lot of what
they're doing but damn there's she is
moving along the super power speed
really fast oh yeah that she just
learned that she had them one thing
about it that's P that portal down
yeah we can't take these
guys yeah why would they want to
[Music]
leave
I feel like Ekko is going to be
connected to her bloodline yeah I
definitely think this connects I don't
feel like her character will be in live
action but I think her character will
connect to her blood like years
Generations ago ancestors yeah or the
legend of kahori influences
her take revenge it's what Heroes do I
mean save people yeah yeah yeah but also
murdered violence and blue give us our
release this is
Unchained
oo that's cool again the horrors and
wonders they're really good at capturing
it the
unknown I got
[Music]
dead whoa she like
saon
damn that's so cool from her over the
POV that's badass oh my God even like
the elements the Great Sound is on in
this episode
too I love everything's going on in the
background yeah the depth is the deepest
I've
[Music]
seen that's messed up uh you guys are
you're literally Canon
[Music]
guys wow this music is
beautiful she slowed it The Melancholy
is very much underscored I will say even
though she got her powers quick and
she's like still invested I'm still so
emotionally invested in her that's the
IR very impressive yeah normally that
gets me away from being invested but I'm
very invested in a
[Music]
[Applause]
character wa that's a cool image lead
the Rebellion oh my
God cool stop his faing I didn't know if
they'd come that's
cool wow it is like a catharsis wh if
scenario got rid of the settlers the
bearing
the what if then we wouldn't have the
show that's true any this
yeah ooh
smash is
facing had a bunch of spit come out of
my mouth decimate him stay in the video
damn look
at now you guys are buried in
there I I I really hope they got like
actual Native American people to consult
on
[Music]
this unit
all the skill they developed from
buffalo hunting kord's Victory wasn't
because she merely chose the right path
because she remained true to her course
unwavering in the face of both
Devastation and miracles alike hell yeah
is often what burns brightest what
elevates an individual to something
more this feels more like a Disney
Animation than is the animation lately
yes good
point
who's this guy Benedict
[Music]
Cumberbatch the people whose Nation
you're trying to take just invaded yours
and they'd be so superstitious those
people be like
[Applause]
terrified
she learned
Spanish trying to say that they should
work
[Music]
together love that
symbolism the Miracles of the sky world
to bring peace to the their neighbors
Bravo there he is World Peace in record
time sure that'll last but I digress and
I've been looking for you for a long
time that's how she gets recruited not
by a good
Benedict don't we only use Benedict in
the thumbnail we need to get a white man
in there the Conqueror get the
views uh is he not
Supreme the
whitean oh
jeez wow holy
balls yeah we watched a lot of what if
today but what's really made it easy is
the clothes were
weing he's not wrong we're comfortable I
I I find my transitions more amusing
than anyone else as the comfort of the
day is resting completely on these oh
that's incredible Mohawk Nation who
collaborated like we we had hoped oh
yeah seriously what what I would say is
collaborating with other artists to help
bring animated shirts to life is the
deepest collaboration you could hope for
at reation sha.com is a great way to
look good and support the Chanel and be
comfortable you know what I'm saying
five hours Greg six hour we're we're
deep in where we at it doesn't matter at
this point doesn't matter what is time
in the Multiverse in the TVA we're all
trapped in it COI yeah I think you
should go first ah as the whiter of
us all right here we are uh I liked the
World building I did are you trying to
steal the show yep I'm going to conquer
it are you trying to take away I'm going
to first are you trying to claim
ownership over what was tray here now I
am I did this I this is my victory this
show this episode uh I really enjoyed
the World building uh and both visually
and that it was like so full of depth
that you could see the world and I I
really enjoyed the feeling of
exploration because of the depth right
like it not only had a story that was
exploratory and you mentioned a few
times the fear and the intensity and the
adventure sense but also by using the
animation to paint more detail in the
depth it also felt like you were
exploring not only narratively but
visually and I thought that was really
interesting because it's a story about
exploration and I found myself not only
being curious about the characters
narrative exploration but visually
exploring the background I sure that was
conscious but I I don't know if I've
ever noticed it so pointedly where I was
distracted by the foreground and
background being disperate and then I
found myself noticing it and then
thinking oh that's cool because it ties
into What exploration would feel like
and that that making the whole feeling
more immersive so I dug that um
character I did obviously have the 30
minute problem of having to develop uh
the who the character was have the
origin story get powers get the power
strong enough to take on the villain
have a conclusion that's not fair to any
character it did obviously have to move
along fairly quickly but I did really
enjoy that the powers felt
so magical they felt so part of the
Earth but like really there was a a
spirit to it that I really dug so even
though the power acquisition and use was
far too fast I did really enjoy the the
tangibility of that that
Wonder so what I heard from that was
looking at all that open land in the
depth mhm the you wanted to take no for
me I want to go all back back there and
up here foreground mine background go as
soon as possible because it looks
available they're cluttering it
frankly they could move
along there this is a really interesting
story to me
because uh you know like I'm I'm well
educated on the subject cuz I saw
killers of the flower man and and
Pocahontas which Disney film to my
understanding kills of the flower Moon
not very accurate Pocahontas documentary
extremely accurate yeah surprised How
brave they were truly can you paint with
all the colors of the wind no and the
love story between those two my God the
passion I can't believe they took they
absolutely the mutual passion the the
not one directional the theual
passion oh jeez
dark joke it's a dark joke of course we
pled in this mood on this episode um
it's it's an interesting story to tell
because uh like it's a
very rightfully so it's still a very
sensitive subject as it should be
despite whatever awkward jokes Co are
making it's a very serious subject and
then they tell this um almost cathartic
like story of world PE I was I was
joking about it like what if if they
didn't conquer and like we're going to
do that story that's the story they're
they made what if Pocahontas got hurt
it's like Tarantino telling is like Jano
story or like what if the glorious
bastards killed Hitler they did it on oh
they're doing this they're actually
doing the tail of what if they were
imbued with something that allowed them
to keep to to rival but what was neat
was they didn't use it through like you
know typical Western tradition of giving
some bows and arrows you know right
right yeah let's appropriate their
culture just enough to make it about how
we perceive them they they interpreted
the Tesseract capabilities as something
one with Mother Earth yeah that they cuz
that they are like spiritually in tune
with and are able to absorb because it's
like looks like what the Conquistadors
that they don't get any absorption no
cuz they're not connected to the world
yeah even when they go into the other
realm they uh the I forget what the did
they say who the people are is are
is it I don't know like the people who
consulted um I think the Mohawk nation
is is who they were representing in
animation in real life cuz I know in
okay EO it's kamanche Nation right so
this is a different Nation um not all
Native American people are the same
there's not one First Nation what under
God indivisible um with liberty and
justice for all the people that were
conquered uh Kenny I have no idea I
pronounce like Kenan Kenyan
I yeah I don't know how to pronounce
that anyway uh what were we talking
about before that Co I'm so sorry uh we
were talking about buy a shirt guys by
buying shirts which supports our nation
supports us the reject Nation to to talk
to keep doing videos of this quality of
caliber it is so we literally we if we
known this was the episode we would not
have been committed to the slap Happy
we've been filming for 5 hours version
of this episode we should probably take
be actually sincere and like focused up
oh I we're so sorry um but I I I you
were talking about how the absorption of
the Tesseract was really beautifully
tied the spirit yeah yeah so I love I
love the uh what they're embodied with
with the power set to be able to take
back what is theirs right rightfully so
and then for them and they shared the
Earth and they said that your health is
our health I thought that was beautiful
and I me as much as I made my Tarantino
comparisons Tarantino would have been
like we're killing everyone oh we're
going to Spain and we're murdering
yeah it would have been just a violent
bloodfest and then they wanted peace
their health is your health which ties
into the Earth that such a beautiful
sentiment yeah yeah there was a lot of
beauty here and I do think on the
animation level this is when they
decided we have to do our it's already
been great and far exceeding um season 1
and what they did here was superb like
this felt we're often hearing about
Disney Animation not feeling that grand
or feeling like Disney Animation this F
this felt like Disney animation like
this is a real short film we're watching
do you know how we uh we've talked about
how Age of Ultron was the first thing
Disney Acquired and then they you know
how we talked about the mic thing and
that it's not a
toothpick remember it's literally in
everyone's ear when you're playing with
it do you remember in Age of Ultron when
Pocahontas the not Pocahontas the
Pinocchio song um Age of Ultron uses it
which fits for the narrative story but
everybody was like oh the disi Aon
remember that era and ever since there's
been the occasional Disney and every so
often like oo that do feel Disney I say
this in Reverse this is a compliment
this was really cool because it felt
like a Disney story in Marvel in a
positive way not that they Marvel
muddled Disney or that Disney muddled
Marvel this felt like a beautiful Union
of Disney Animation that from our
childhood and a Disney story but with
Marvel allowing it to be a little bit
more it's had an edge to it because of
how it ended and it felt like you know a
superhero story this felt like what
Disney and Marvel would would happen in
organically and that was really cool
some people will immediately jump on the
fact because it's a female character too
of like like we we were criticizing the
whole thing of her learning really fast
right but still managing to be
emotionally invested in the character
you know let's not forget drct strange
shows up at the end of this episode he
learned pretty freaking fast too yeah so
I mean she learned a little faster but
yeah 20 minutes what what are you GNA do
it's 20 minutes um and I I I think
what's really neat about it
is I think you sent in the trailer
reaction of of how like Harley Quinn was
invented for Batman the Animated Series
and now it's character in the comics and
I feel like we could do the same thing
with her and they're we're often hearing
about oh you know why are you gender
swapping or or race swapping a character
just create a new one well now they've
done it yeah here you go now they've
created the character and into a
multiversal cannon that could tie into
the main cannon in some way I do think
this power set in some way l AG wise can
tie cuz it can still tie into Echo and
something I think it will whether it's
like a legend whether it's uh you know
another tribe Legend whether it is
directly to her I'm really curious th% U
but I do I like your your parallel that
with Harley Quinn because that's a
character I love especially because her
invention I totally um culturally
appropriated your parallel I you took
myally cited that you said it
interaction and then you went I like
that parallel that you said hey that
thing that I said like your parallel I
like my past Theory no but like Harley
Quinn it's a good point you just made
where did that come from man July Koy
was smart uh no but like uh Harley Quinn
I love because it's a character about
escaping um un unlikely odds and it
could have been a gender swapped Joker
but they they made her a character that
was kind of in a horrible situation
because of Joker and she escapes that
I've always love the idea of a character
being stronger than its invention itself
like what a what a powerful thing that a
character exceeded its medium what a
powerful thing that a character is able
to and in this case it beautifully
mirrors the character itself like Harley
Quinn escaped the shackles of being just
a TV sidekick to the Joker and she
escaped narratively by being stronger
than the Joker and able to leave that
that oppression I would love if a story
about a a First Nation character that is
telling the story of what if they
weren't all destroyed gets to be a true
First Nation hero because so many of
those people didn't get the chance to
exist in modern day uh there are still
obviously uh First Nation people and
Indigenous folk um to this day but we
the the scale is so astronomically small
because of the atrocities this is saying
what if didn't happen so I'd love if if
similarly there was an opportunity for a
presence that isn't around in day-to-day
life to the scale it should be by having
a character that gets to represent a
nation of people that doesn't have a
voice HT as much yeah I thought this was
a really well done episode overall guys
uh I've been really loving what I
thought this would feel like a chore
we've texted a lot this week about like
all right I like should we just skip it
yeah especially like the the holidays
and and maybe this won't get views or
whatever but but I've been enjoying it
in terms of our experience we've had fun
I've had fun doing this with you we
still got a few more to go and I've had
fun not just because we're filming
together but because it's genuinely been
surprisingly it's not just better it is
a caliber what is it a metaphor for
another French I swear it's like wow
they just it was okay and now it's like
a whole new caliber of this is not just
better it is it has reached a whole new
terrain of great I know other franchises
have done that yeah but all the ones I
think are genre changes alien is good
aliens is different but like they're
both good I can't think of something
that like oh God why can't we've been
for hours there's so many that have done
it and I just can't think of so many
sequels that are better than the
original just like wow no you should
just watch this one I can't I can't
think of any right very tired oh parks
and re season 2 that's a fair yeah
because Parks Rec Season one is good but
Parks Rec Season 2 gets
great all right guys yeah there you go
this is the Parkson Rec Parks Rec
Marvel you're welcome starlord it is the
parks and rec bring it all back to Chris
PR Parks and Rec surely is the parks
direct season 2 of Marvel
television guys we need a
I gotta record re moon it's a it's a b
you you scheduled a bold day then I got
to edit just a bad normally I my forever
made it this far normally it's like two
hours of shooting and then a bunch of
computer work for like 10 been here over
five hours and now it's today it's the
inverse it's like a few hours of editing
and just a whole bunch of filming cuz I
want to have Christmas Day Christmas
deck have a Christmas deck you a good
better thing to power through than stuff
like this still grateful have you all
here thanks for joining
me that's Say by bye now
[Music]
bye